certainly for the app there are six
hundred and eighteen thousand nine
hundred and three people
pinged uh in england and wales uh in
the week uh to july the fourteenth
that's
up sixteen point six percent on the
previous week
which perhaps reflects partly the uh the
rapid increase
in number of cases therefore you'd
expect the number of people being told
have been in contact with the positive
case would
would also increase and certainly um if
you look at the number of uh positive
test results being linked to the app
uh that's also up um in the the week
the most recent week 118 000
uh positive test results linked to the
app uh up 33
percent uh on the previous week i think
this
reflects the rapidly accelerate
accelerating
uh epidemic this third wave that we have
at the moment where cases really are
streaking upwards
uh much faster than hospital admissions
and
deaths of course and that is putting
huge pressure
on the economy uh as we know with people
struggling to staff shifts and so on
uh and i think there will be increasing
pressure on the government to do
something about this
they have said or from august the 16th
those who've been double jabbed
uh won't have to isolate in the same way
but of course this isn't a straight
um binary situation it's not that on the
on midnight on that night everything
becomes okay
the value of the app slowly decreases
the closer and closer we get to that
date
when more people have had two doses of
the vaccine